question orale de Monsieur Bernard
Fournier à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture des grands alimentaires et
de la forêt
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaite tirer votre
attention et celle du gouvernement sur
les problèmes de restauration scolaire
rencontrés par une des communes de mon
département juillet ce cas spécifique
pour être très bien arrivé à d'autres
communes alors que l'école de juillet
disposait d'un service de restauration
de parenthèse appréciée par les élèves
les parents et la municipalité grâce au
repas fournis par le dernier
restaurateur de la commune le maire a
été contraint de chercher un autre
fournisseur pour la rentrée scolaire
en effet la suite dans le contrôle de la
direction du porte mental de la
protection des populations le
restaurateur a dû cesser dans un délai
très court la livraison des repas à la
cantine si la commune devait réaliser
les travaux de mise en conformité ce qui
a été fait la raison principale vient de
plusieurs textes qui sont très
restrictifs
l'arrêté du 8 juin 2006 modifié relatif
à l'agrément sanitaire des
établissements étant sur le marché des
produits d'origine animale ou des
denrées contenant des produits d'origine
animale indiquent dans son annexe 4 le
nombre de repas ou de fractions de repas
pouvant être livrées sous couvert de la
dérogation à des établissements de
restauration collective
il limite la livraison à seulement 150
pas hebdomadaires pour la quantité
par ailleurs conformément au règlement
européen numéro 853 2004 cette activité
doit rester marginale pour le restaurant
commercial
puisqu'il a l'obligation de ne pas
dépasser le seuil maximal de 30 % de
repas servis à l'extérieur
cette réglementation extrêmement
contraignante risque de pénaliser
gravement le dernier restaurant de la
commune de juillet qui survit disons-le
grâce à cette activité complémentaire il
va contraindre la municipalité à faire
appel à des cuisines centrales éloignées
pour maintenir le service de
restauration scolaire cela contre tout
bon sens favorisera l'achat de produits
industriels en dehors de stéréois et
augmentera les temps de transport au
détriment d'environnement aussi en plein
débat sur un simplification des normes
applicables aux collectivités il
apparaît urgent d'examiner celle
concernant les relations entre les
cantines scolaires et les restaurants en
conséquent je souhaite connaître madame
la ministre vos intentions et celles du
gouvernement sur cette question je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est Madame Dominique Bertinotti mis
chargé de la famille
monsieur le sénateur je vous demande
tout d'abord de bien vouloir excuser
Monsieur Le Foll qui est en déplacement
en Afrique du Sud avec le président de
la République et donc qui m'a chargé de
vous transmettre la réponse qu'il
souhaite vous apporter les difficultés
rencontrées dans la commune de juillet
dans votre département dont vous faites
pas au gouvernement pourra
approvisionner son service de
restauration scolaire concerne
l'application de l'arrêté du 8 juin 2006
relatif à l'agrément ou à l'autorisation
des établissements mettant sur le marché
des produits d'origine animale ou des
denrées concernant ce type de produit en
application de la réglementation
européenne réglement de 2004 les
établissements fournissant des repas à
des restaurants collectifs doivent
disposer de l'agrément sanitaire
européen en appliquant les règles
d'hygiène qui sont attachées sauf s'il
remplissent les conditions pour
bénéficier de la dérogation à l'O
sanitaire c'est-à-dire si leur activité
reste marginale localisée et restreinte
ainsi un commerce de détails
restaurateur ou traiteur par exemple
peut livrer des cantines scolaires en
bénéficiant d'une dérogation à
l'obligation d'agrément sanitaire sous
réserve de respecter les limites prévues
par l'arrêté du 8 juin 2006 soit 400
repas ou fraction de repas hebdomadaire
dans la limite de 30% de sa production
totale ou 150 repas hebdomadaires si
livres jusqu'à 100% de sa production
totale
les possibilités de dérogation offerte
au commerce de détails ainsi que les
simplifications en matière d'agrément
sanitaire sont autant d'éléments en
faveur du développement des circuits de
proximité en limitant les exigences tout
en maintenant un niveau sanitaire élevé
je dois vous indiquer en revanche qu'il
n'est pas possible d'assouplir davantage
les conditions permettant de bénéficier
de la dérogation à l'agrément car cela
risquerait de créer des distorsions de
concurrence économiques entre opérateurs
disposant d'un agrément et ce
bénéficiant d'une dérogation pour des
activités de même nature
l'obligation d'agrément sanitaire
n'implique toutefois pas nécessairement
d'investissement supplémentaires le
contenu du dossier d'agrément est
d'ailleurs normalement adapté à la
taille de l'établissement en question
par ailleurs le droit européen impose à
tous les établissements du secteur
alimentaire qu'ils soient ou non agréés
la mise en place
un plan de maîtrise sanitaire ce plan
comprend les bonnes pratiques d'hygiène
l'analyse des points critiques pour
mieux les maîtriser ainsi que la
traçabilité et la gestion des
non-conformités ces éléments constituent
l'essentiel du dossier d'agrément exigé
pour livrer à la restauration collective
dans le cadre des efforts entrepris par
le gouvernement en matière de
simplification des démarches
administratives et de simplification le
ministère de l'Agriculture m'aide à
disposition en ligne sur son site
internet mais également dans ses
services déconcentrés des dossiers type
d'agrément pour l'activité de
charcuterie salaison plat cuisinés qui
viennent d'ailleurs d'être actualisées
suite à la simplification du dossier de
demande d'agrément intervenir récemment
tout établissement concerné par cette
obligation peut donc céder de ce
document pour établir son dossier
d'agrément sanitaire merci
chers collègues c'est Fournier oui très
brièvement Madame le Ministre d'abord
merci pour votre réponse je vous que si
je puis me permettre l'expression je
reste un peu sur ma fin
j'ai quand partir obtenu
une réponse concernant la simplification
d'un certain nombre de règles et de
normes ce que nous ne voudrions pas dans
nos communes rurales notamment c'est que
petit à petit ces derniers commerces
disparaissent qu'ils soient remplacé par
des entreprises industrielles qui sont
éloignées des
cantines scolaires des écoles que ce
soit des produits du coût des produits
industriels qui seront servis aux
enfants et avec un éloignement très
important parfois par rapport
au lieu de fabrication des produits et
de la cantine scolaire
voilà et donc
je suis un peu déçu par votre réponse je
dois le dire très très franchement en
tout cas j'ai noté que et bien il
fallait l'agrément sanitaire ce que ne
manquera pas de demander
l'établissement auquel je faisais
allusion je vous remercie merci chers
collègues